le feu s'est déclaré vers 8 heures ce
matin dans cet immeuble de sept étages
l'incendié est parti d'un appartement du
6e son occupante une femme d'une
quarantaine d'années s'est défenestrée
pour échapper aux flammes
10 mi temps je suis passé il n'y avait
rien et bon après il ya des jeunes qui y
a le feu il ya le feu ya le feu les
pompiers et la dame s'est jetée planète
vous la connaissez votre voisine travail
ont dû retraiter lé travail moment de
repartir dès fois le matin
[Musique]
communique pas beaucoup quoi elle vit
seule je sais pas je pense que oui
puisque c'est un studio
la victime a survécu à sa chute
gravement blessée elle a été prise en
charge par les secours
les pompiers ont également porté
assistance à une dizaine d'autres
habitants nous avons eu en tout a
déploré dix autres victimes des
personnes qui ont été légèrement
intoxiquées par les fumées et il ya eu
des évacuations c'est vous qui avez
assuré l'évacuation de certains
habitants de l'immeuble c'est ça tout à
fait donc les pompiers à leur arrivée se
sont attachés à procéder à l'évacuation
des autres appartements sur les paliers
et nous avons dû réaliser donc deux
mises en sécurité au moyen de la grande
échelle en plus de l'appartement de la
victime plusieurs logements sont
désormais inutilisable une enquête a été
ouverte pour déterminer l'origine de
l'incendié